Today I have followed out we can buy Ivermectin over the color from the drug stores. I've heard a lot of good information about this drug and cancer can we take it and what would be the benefit.
So I have been hesitant to comment about Ivermectin in the past because it's a prescription medication most places.
If you just do a Google scholarship search on Ivermectin and cancer, you'll find that there's a number of studies that are very positive on Ivermectin and cancer.
So I don't see any problem with taking Ivermectin. The only thing I would suggest was that it is a medication and we, you know, even though it's long use medication.
It was initially in the market years and years ago, very, very, very few side effects. I would still think that it would be best to close it.
I can't any medication can, you know, affect you in negative ways, but it can have very positive effects. So I know there are some people that take Ivermectin every day.
And it's like, I just want to go, but why? I mean, I'm talking to people who don't even have cancer. You know, so I don't know that I would suggest anything like that.
But I don't see it. Let's say if you're just trying to protect yourself against cold or some other weird virus that they could all to pulse it might be a good thing to have it in your arsenal might be a good thing.
I do think that a lot of medications you can become sensitive to meeting that if you're taking it all the time, you're not going to get as much benefit from it.
And saving it, having it in your arsenal to take, let's say if your cancer's doing well and you're doing really well, then I don't know that I would change that and take that.
You know, you don't have a virus and you're feeling well, it might be good to have it in your arsenal if you do need to take it. But I think it is.
And obviously it had that phenomenal success with COVID. That's why they're dancing. I think that right question may have been me. Yes, it was. I called it. I don't think my question was very clear. I said to the cheek swab last week with requesting new right frequencies.
I'm sure how long I should expect to wait for the new frequencies. I already sent an email stating that I could get the new frequency files via flash flash drive or even download them from an email or drop box.
If they're too large to save money shipping flash drive.
Yeah, we cannot. One thing we can't do when we've never been able to do is to email the frequencies.
Because they because of the way that the folder is you can't even if you put it in a folder, I can email them. You have to download it. You have to take that and put it. That's really confusing. That's even harder to do.
So if you feel comfortable with me doing a flash drive, I'll just send the first one. So I don't know if you heard the answer. If you had to feel comfortable about what do you do?
And again, the instructions are on the members side and right.
I know you've done the flash drive before, but the version 6.4 is different than the version 6.0. So that's what I will say with version 6.4. It's very different how the program goes in to the right program.
It won't go into the main body of the program.
So in version 6.4, you have to click if there's two more clicks you have to make. So you open program on the version 6.4 right now. If you just got a 6.4 on your computer, if you open the program, you'll see all the right programs.
But you cannot put a custom program in that folder. You have to go over the left and click documents. There's four little things you can click on. One of them is documents. The second one down.
And then in documents, you'll open up that and there will be nothing in there. So you have to create a folder in that called true right frequencies. And then you put your custom folder in that. So anybody that has a version 6.4 that I did that on.
Understands that completely go, yeah, I know we have two more steps that now anybody started with us recently. They don't know that at one point in time there was two last steps to get into their program.
They understand that they have to open up the true right program, hit open program, then go to documents, then go to three frequencies, and then go to their program.
So 6.4 is different. So you feel comfortable doing that. I'll just send you a flash drive. If you're confused at what I just said, it is written down in the member site.
If you're like, I was totally lost, that'd be better to send me your computer and I'll put it in. Either way, just think about it. Look at the instructions and then either email, let's say, yeah, I feel good.
Send me the flash drive and I'll do that. Where do we find the clues as to how our cancer is driven. Is it in the initial cheek swan. Yes. And resulting program.
No, well, we're talking about the right program. No, you won't see, get a clue of that. Or do we get the info from the genetic report? No. So, so dependent on when you started with us, we used to be very open about the causes.
We have causes, balancers, and then food drivers. It's just when we got attacked by the AMA, and we had to be careful with our terminology.
So we had to kind of take that terminology out that what was the cause and what was the drivers. We had to be more careful with that terminology.
But I'm at a point right now, I just don't care. They can just throw you at you. I just don't care anything. So, when we look, when you look at diet, so when you talk about what is how our cancer is driven, let's clarify that phrase.
So cancer could be caused from something. So anything that gets inside of a cell that damages the nucleus at the DNA, the replication cycle in the cell goes into rapid replication. That is the initial cause of the cancer.
And you could be moved us to find that out to help deal with that. So it doesn't cause the same thing in a double cell. Now, understand, even if you could magically make that all go away.
Let's say if the cause that got inside the cell that damaged the DNA that caused it to go into rapid replication, let's pretend it was a Michael Thompson.
If you could magically remove all the Michael toxins from your body, it still doesn't solve the problem that the care the cells are still in rapid replication because the damage was done.
But if you get rid of that, we know that your body is susceptible to Michael toxins as a cause of cancer, we don't want it to cause another cancer or cancer somewhere else.
So it's essential in my mind to find out what that causes and deal with it and deal with other potential causes, other toxins, other biotoxins. That's why we do that testing.
We want to deal with all the core of entities. That's why I talked about autoimmune diseases and deal with those core of readings that could be causes of cancer.
Secondly, a driver of cancer could be a term that we use to what is fueling the cancer. So remember, a cells that are in rapid replication are very hungry. So hungry cells need a fuel source.
That's why we take you off of certain things. Dairy is a common fuel source. That's why I recommend everybody with cancer go on a lower sugar diet and keeping your glucose levels.
If you test them with a computer at a low range will also be helpful.
If you want to meet everybody needs to go ketogenic doesn't need everybody needs to, you know, do anything specifically we want to test for what are fuel sources and that can change so in cheek swab testing, if that changes ice, make that note and tell you stay off of this food too, you know, change your diet, I make those changes.
That's all done, that is all done on the cheek so if, you know, we always recheck that driver. So, you don't have to request that.
Okay, so you don't have to tell me, Patty, I will just send you a question.
Originally, dairy was a driver with diets and no dairy, this cheek swab.
Dairy was not a drive, no, so I don't rephrase it so if, if, if I say, there's a different driver than yes, so if I don't tell you again that there is a driver and I only make changes on the cheek swab.
So when I said you back information on the cheek swab, it's just that any changes so stay is dairy free as possible.
But that brings up another question. Can I ever just relax a bit on the driver and the answer is always yes. So if you've eliminated, you know, a main fuel source for a period of time.
Is it okay to have butter once in a while, or is it okay to put some cream and like coffee a few times a week. The answer is yes, always has been yes, because you can't, you're never going to completely eliminate the fuel source.
So that's kind of a foul. So you're never going to be able to completely. So I also have always said, this is a diet, it's not a dogma, it's not a religion, you're not, you know, first, you're not sitting by, you know, having some butter on toast or something like that.
So just make sure it and I will say also that it can be dangerous to even have that thought in your mind because that is producing anxiety.
And what does anxiety do, but stimulant is sympathetic reaction, which can be the worst thing for your cancer.
And I've said over and over, you know, a hundred times, it's a lot of times the people that do the best amounts of cancer and end up having the best success and the people that are like, no, tell me what to do. I'll do the best I can.
And I'm going to leave the results to go. The ones that are frantic and anxious and worried and concerned and analyzing everything and getting, you know, having OCD issues about their cancer.
Again, the problem with that is it stimulates glutamate, it stimulates sympathetic dominance, it shuts down your immune system and it shuts down your detoxification pathways.
All those things are not good. So don't ever beat yourself out about, you know, I don't like goodness. It was my, you know, suns birthday or something.
So I had a bite of cake, but it was all guilty. It's not a sin. That's not how we're supposed to even act with, with spiritual things.
But I always spirit doesn't beat you well, but you make mistakes. He, she molds you, shapes you. Sometimes that's not pleasant, but he, he's gentle and graceful and merciful and done.
And that's the way you need to be with yourself when it comes to your balance.
All right, with that, we will say good night. I hope you all have a wonderful night and go do something fun.
That's the light out.
I'm giving you the light out.
All right, God bless you all. I'll be praying for you. I'll be well.